we must ask you a question do you think
we live in a society that can handle
another secret justice league stash
well hold on to your razors because
footage from the set of zack snyder's
justice league reshoots just leaked
and it shows that jared leto's character
once sported a very stylish strip of
facial hair over his upper lip
can we get release the joker stash
trending for the longest time
when it came to the justice league movie
all anyone could talk about was
mustaches
that's because henry cavill was
contractually prohibited from shaving
his mission and possible mustache when
he did reshoots for the 2017 theatrical
version of the film
and the vfx artists had to digitally
remove it in post-production
the effect was jarring and was yet one
more reason so many fans wanted zack
snyder's original cut of the movie
released
but as it turns out you can't keep a
good stash down
now you can add yet another digital
shave to your list
here's what happened this is
unbelievable
insiders tell us that leto was thrilled
about snyder's invitation to revisit the
joker role
before now he'd only been able to play
the joker in 2016's suicide squad
but snyder wanted to bring him back for
his new four-hour
version of justice league to prepare for
the reshoot the infamously committed
method actor decided to dive deep
into the history of the joker on film
blending bits and pieces from
all of the actors who came before him in
his own performance
he discovered that the very first actor
to play the part of the joker
caesar romero in the 1966 batman
television series
refused to shave his mustache so the
showrunners just covered it up with
white paint
letto decided that the only way to honor
him was to grow a mustache of his own
but with a signature jared leto twist in
a leaked excerpt from a
soon-to-be-published interview with
follicle monthly
leto said i needed to feel the spirit of
caesar within me so i found out where he
used to live in la
and i used my joker skills to break in i
stole all the mustache wax and beard oil
i could find
rubbing as much as i could into my own
mustache and drinking whatever was left
i now have the romero essence
i love this guy he's
so intense according to our source
when leto showed up on set he'd already
been in character as the joker for over
a month
having applied his character's makeup
weeks ago and grown his dark bushy
mustache over it
which he'd also dyed green as he got
ready to shoot his scenes
leto explained the mustache's backstory
apparently after darkseid's forces took
over the earth the joker's twisted mind
snapped even further as the mustache
grew the joker began believing
it was his own sick psycho sidekick
which he named harry
full name harry quinn he refused to
shave harry
believing his prickly partner in crime
was all that stood in the way of the
earth being turned
into the next apocalypse snyder knowing
better than to ask leto to break
character and having limited time to
shoot the new scene
just got the cameras rolling our sources
on the set reportedly heard snyder
defending the actor's decision to
worried producers
saying quote i know it'll cost us
another 30 million but you gotta admit
it's a pretty good joke
that said harry wasn't the only thing
that hit the cutting room floor
apparently leto improvised several lines
that directly referenced his mustache
dialogue like do you want to know how i
got this mustache
and did you ever try to shave a mustache
in the pale moonlight
and top this joaquin and finally wait'll
they get a load of this
mustache another source inside dc comics
offices revealed that leto had
actually sent the publisher hundreds of
letters demanding that the joker be
drawn with a mustache for the next 10
years
as of the making of this video dc still
has yet to comment on our question
about whether or not they might want to
add a little beard too
most interestingly our source said that
since footage of the mustache cut
leaked leto has been cast in the
upcoming direct-to-quibby spin-off
mission impossible kitchen nightmares
what do you think of this startling
revelation
are you team stashy or team shavy do you
know what day it is
what a joke check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about the snyder cut are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one